All of the systems,
beliefs,
emotions,
and experiences that we call life or taking place on a tiny rock floating
through space.
During our time here,
we've discovered that our rock is one of the only ones that has all the
conditions necessary for sustaining life.
What we can't figure out for sure is what sparked brought together all these
conditions that led us into existence.
What clues have we found so far and why does it seem like life on earth came
from something extra terrestrial?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if life didn't originate on earth.
The earliest signs of life on earth are molecules that are so complex that some
scientists say it's unlikely they just popped up here.
So what if they formed somewhere else in space first and then traveled to our
planet?
How would they get here?
No one knows for sure how or where life honored started,
but there are plenty of conflicting scientific theories out there to better
understand them.
Let's start with something we can all agree on.
Earth is about four and a half billion years old and some of the earliest
fossils we've found our about 3.7 billion years old.
So we know that life started at some point in between and that's where things
start to get complicated.
Some of the earliest evidence for life on earth contains a complex molecule
called ribonucleic acid or RNA.
RNA is made up of thousands of smaller molecules that are connected in a
particular pattern and it was one of the driving forces behind life on earth.
But the big question that divides the scientific community is where did RNA come
from?
Well,
one option is that it came from outer space and no,
we don't mean by way of advanced aliens planting their seeds,
although that would make for an interesting video.
Anyways,
what we're talking about is called Panspermia.
The idea that living organisms or genetic materials could have been transported
to earth through some sort of natural phenomenon like an asteroid.
It might sound crazy,
but it's actually plausible.
In 2012 Danish scientists found the building blocks of RNA in a star system,
400 light years away,
proving that the compounds necessary to forge life on earth.
It could be created in space,
but then how did they end up on earth?
Well,
there are two main theories and both involve asteroids.
Number One,
an asteroid could have brought these genetic materials to earth by crashing into
its surface.
Or number two,
an asteroid could have crashed into Mars,
hit a spot,
the contained micro organisms and sent the debris in this space which eventually
found its way to earth.
Both of these instances have happened before and research shows that some life
forms like bacteria and fungus could definitely survive the trip to our planet,
but some remained skeptical.
Choosing to believe that life on earth was sparked by natural phenomena like
lightening or good old fashioned chemical reactions.
Yeah,
so even if Panspermia doesn't turn out to be our true origin story,
it doesn't mean that asteroids aren't spreading life to any of the other
billions of planets out there right now laying the groundwork for future
civilizations like ours.
But that's a topic for another.
What if.